I think most people have a dramatic
underestimation of how much volume it
takes to be successful they're like okay
I should go on five dates and then find
the girl I'm gonna marry like what if it
was 500 to find the right girl you're
going to marry we ended up doing 400
episodes before we made it to the top 10
on the podcast it's just this volume
game you get the skill from the volume
if I can just decrease the action
threshold for people to begin and be
okay with the fact that they're going to
suck and it is okay to suck you should
expect to suck and it would be
unreasonable for you to be good if you
haven't done it before it's the
expectation that destroys their ability
to be successful because they expect to
win on the first shot and no one does